[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRASHANTH SANAGAVARAPU:
Today we're
going to talk about
how we are optimizing
our SRE 's effectiveness,
enabling our engineering
teams to deliver applications in
a reliable, stable performance.
And providing digital
experience that
matches our first
in class journalism.
Agenda is to go or
some of the challenges
that we have in our
environment, and talk
about how we work as a team.
And then Vinessa will
unpack some of the ways
how we are building operational
maturity across the teams using
product mindset.
And then I'll walk you
into an engagement model
that we use to work with
the engineering teams
and develop tooling
or lessons that could
be applied across the arc.
And then we'll also take
you through some of the ways
that we evangelize
our SRE practices
that are meant to drive the
culture change that you'd
need when you have your
applications running
in the cloud.
Firstly, the challenges.
In 2018 we transformed
our infrastructure.
We shut down our data centers
and migrated to the cloud.
This transformation was
not just about migration.
But the tooling that we used
to have and the culture we
had around how we manage
our infrastructure.
We adopted
contemporization and put
in tools that would enable us
to build in a cloud native way.
I'll talk more into that
tooling, but during that time
we built the
tooling that enabled
our engineers, basically, to
deliver applications faster.
And the migration was
successful and out on time.
This all sounds like
happily ever after.
But right after
the migration, we
realized our real SRE
work has just begun.
Let's take a look at one
of our business workflow
that we have that
spans across the teams.
The workflow is
basically newsroom
trying to publish an
article and it shows up
on our front end applications.
The editor would compile
the article in our content
management system, hit Publish.
The article lands on
our publishing pipeline.
And the content APIs
formats this content
into a way that is consumable
by all the front end apps.
At a high level, this
is a simple workflow.
But during the migration,
what we did was
we enabled the teams
by providing autonomy
over their cloud
infrastructure by giving them
full control of their
infrastructure in their GCP
projects.
So if you were to look at the
content management system here.
It is made of
microservices, but the team
that manages that
system owns end-to-end
of all the microservices on
[INAUDIBLE] in their own GCP
project.
And so are the other
systems in this workflow.
The challenge here is
our user experience
depends on all these systems
that we are seeing here.
We did not have
an aggregated view
of how we measure our
user experience when teams
are working in their
own GCP projects
and working with their own
infrastructure in a way
that they're missing out on
how their system is impacting
a wider user experience.
From an engineering standpoint,
there are two users here.
One, the newsroom that's
trying to publish an article.
And, two, the readers
that are consuming.
So we had to rethink
and we saw a need
for building those aggregated
views of measuring how our user
experience gets impacted
when these systems are making
changes.
So initially I spoke
about the tooling
that we built that
enabled the migration.
Basically what we
did was we adapted
to the cloud native tools.
We have consistency
ICD withdrawn,
and we started using
Kubernetes areas,
and ask Google to manage our
Kubernetes, which is GKE.
We deployed NewYorkTimes.com
on GKE a year ago.
And we have Prometheus
for understanding
how the systems perform.
We also have Fastly
available self-serviceable,
distributed
edge-caching tool that
is basically available for
any front end engineering team
to put their application on.
And we also have transformed
from being this data
center based infrastructure
to infrastructure S
code with Terraform.
And we also have [INAUDIBLE]
to support the applications'
needs like secrets
management with Vault and PKI
management with Vault. So
the tooling is already there.
But what we are
missing is the company
that you don't
see on this slide.
That is the application.
So we have the
tooling, but what we
need is operational
maturity on the teams
to use these tools in a way
that they can build applications
that match their silos, that
match the user experience
that is required from them.
So having that
operational maturity
alongside of these great tools
is a need that we have seen.
So what is the lay of the
land at the New York Times?
We have 400 plus applications.
And we have 40 plus teams
managing 400 applications.
And these applications
range from cloud native,
user facing apps to
enterprise apps that
are built by third
party but the teams
deploy for our internal use.
So there is a wide
variety of these apps.
With those wide
variety there are
wide variety of needs for
these apps to be in the cloud.
That reflects in the teams, too.
The teams have different
experience and skills,
especially around
SRE skills that they
would need to manage depending
on the type of the app.
However, what is consistent
is after the migration
we were asking the
teams to manage
their own infrastructure.
That is consistent,
regardless of what type of app
they use or build.
So what we saw is we as a team
had to work with these teams.
Engage with them and build
skills on their teams
that would enable them
regardless of what type of app
they're managing would
be successful in meeting
their SLOs.
So in the data center world,
we had a centralized ops team.
So we came from that
world to the cloud.
And this centralized ops team
was managing infrastructure
for the teams.
So that is a culture
change that we've
gone through in the last
one and a half years.
But, however, the processes
that we have still
reflect that data center model.
And we still
continue to use them,
which is more like trying to
fit a square peg in round hole.
I'll give you an example.
Our biggest example
that I can think
of when it comes to managing
systems in the data center way
is our priority one
defect management process.
Where it works really well if
we apply it to a single team
because that's what
it is built for,
but when an audit spans
across multiple teams, then
it becomes really hard.
The teams try to
figure out the problem
and then pass that
problem to other teams,
figuring out this is not
the cause that we have.
And it goes to the other
team and goes to another team
until finally, a
resolution is arrived.
So we've seen that
process fail when
we have distributed
engineering teams managing
their own infrastructure.
And we had to rethink the
way how we could manage
our priority one defects.
So that's just an example.
So we had to rethink
about the processes
that we have from
the data center.
How did we address
all these problems?
You can guess it.
Yes, through SRE program.
But how did we do it?
For most of our
teams, when we talk
about how we formed the team
there is always a back story.
And who is an SRE is an
interesting conversation
that I often hear.
But our team is pretty much
what the book prescribes.
We went by the book.
We built tooling and automation
to help our engineering teams
to manage their
production systems.
May be incident management,
may be tracking their SLOs.
The most important
thing that we do
is engage with the
engineering teams.
You engage to build the
operational maturity
on the teams.
It could be on a
specific problem,
or it could be a
tooling app that
might be useful for
other engineering teams.
Or it could just
be anything that
involves building
reliability into the systems.
That's what we engage on
a one on one basis for.
We also provide
documentation on process
as a way to guide these
teams to use our tooling,
to evangelize the SRE practices.
And we go one step further
and provide workshops.
Workshops around how to
be an incident commander.
Workshops around how do
you manage your incidents?
So that's the process
and guidance we provide.
So now you've seen
the challenges.
You've see what we do as a team.
Now my colleague,
Vinessa, will talk
about how the program works to
build that operational maturity
I've been talking about.
VINESSA WAN: Thanks.
Thanks, Prashanth.
So, Product Management mindset.
So, Prashanth mentioned
we had a central team that
controlled all of the
infrastructure decisions
for New York Times applications.
So shifting to GCP and
making that decision
to have now application
development teams manage
their own infrastructure
required a shift
in our thinking.
Our team delivery engineering
with the SRE function
was formed not to control
the infrastructure.
Because other app teams control
their own infrastructure.
We sought to
empower these teams.
So therefore we had to shift
our way of thinking as well.
I know, you get a project
manager for the first time
at a tech conference
you're going
to hear the Agile Manifesto.
But that was a source of
inspiration for how we
decided to operationalize SRE.
Individuals and interactions
over processes and tools.
And it's not to say that the
tooling and processes and all
the cool things
that you see today,
and all the great
things that we do--
I mean, they're vital
to making change.
But what we're
talking about is when
you are aiming that teams
have to be operationally
mature, which
means they're going
to be managing SRE
practices on their own,
that's a culture change.
And that starts with people.
Product management
thinking starts
with viewing our internal
teams as customers.
And what that means is
you have to incentivize
people using teams,
using your tooling,
teams listening to
your guidance, teams
using and applying
your processes.
I'm going to be honest.
This sometimes is the
hardest part of my job.
It would be a lot
easier in the short term
if we just require
teams to use our tools.
But that comes at that
risk because of what
it means if we don't
do this, we risk
not being able to provide
tooling that speeds up
development, that
improves velocity,
that helps teams deliver a
reliable end user experience.
So we, ourselves,
are incentivized
to constantly seek that feedback
and get that data to drive
our decision making process.
Our team formed in March
2016 and we called out
and identified a focus of
how we were going to collect
this feedback and data.
It was going to be around
how teams perceived us.
Why did we need to
measure perception?
Our old infrastructure
and systems teams,
they were perceived as
blockers and bottlenecks
because they had to
control everything
as part of the mission and
the way we were structured.
And so we wanted to change
that perception as well.
We wanted to build
trust with teams
to feel that they can rely
on us, on our tooling,
and our best practices.
So the feedback
process has evolved.
We've been running the
process for a couple of years.
And it's evolved a bit.
But we've come up with
a really stable process.
And it's very much
modeled what you might
see from front end design.
And the process runs
about twice a year.
And the process, it builds
on user empathy as well as
the ability to measure
patterns over time.
We always aim for
balanced representation
because we're building
tools for all of the Times.
And when I say a
balanced representation,
it's not just
hearing from teams,
but recently, we've
also been aiming
to make sure the
non-engineers in the team
understand the value we provide.
Because a lot of times, it's
those folks that actually
control and govern the roadmap.
And then of course it
has to help us plan.
It has to be actionable.
And it's not to say that this
is the only source of input
into our roadmap.
There's always top down
efforts that have to be done,
particularly in the security
and compliance arena
but this is a major input
that fuels what we do
and where our focus will be.
The way we collect
feedback is two parts.
It's a survey and it's
qualitative interviews.
The survey itself is
very much designed
with user empathy in mind.
It's very short.
It's mostly
quantitative questions.
Again, we want to make
it easy for people.
If you make something easy
in terms of getting feedback,
you're going to
get more feedback.
It's obvious, right?
But the fact of the
matter is sometimes
people want to give
a lot of information,
but you can't substitute a
survey with a conversation.
So what we do, and this is
one of my favorite questions.
Our very first question--
let me see if I
can use a pointer--
is we say we value
your feedback.
If you want to talk with
us, leave your name here
and we'll reach out and have
a conversation with you.
And we handle that as part
of the qualitative interview
process.
Now the process actually
started with just a few managers
on the team doing
these interviews.
But we decided to actually
open this whole process up so
that anyone in our
team, any engineer
can sign up to interview
someone or even
scribe for an interview.
This has delivered
benefits, not just in
terms of us being
able to get better
reach in getting more feedback.
It also builds a
lot more empathy.
When you have a
conversation with people,
they feel like
they're being heard,
but it also motivates
our engineers.
I mean, how often in an
internal tooling team
do you actually get to
do a practice like this?
And this is a catalyst
also because it
let us create much better
guidelines and templates
and how we actually create
qualitative interviews.
And so by having this we're able
to collect all this information
in a consistent way.
We take these results
and we synthesize them
as a team to make
sure that we have
a correct view on our findings.
This means if you're
in test automation
or even if you're in SRE,
you are part of this process.
And you're represented.
And then we carve out a
whole week where we dive
into-- and we call it the
team brainstorm week--
and this is when we go
through all the pain points
that people went through.
What are things that we're
doing that we should actually
continue or do more of?
And what are the
opportunities that we
need to explore as
part of our roadmap?
And then of course we
share these results out.
It's very important, I
want to emphasize this,
because sometimes
there's this tendency
to collect this information
and it could be really hard.
It's hard to sometimes
say, yeah we really
didn't do really great at it.
But it's more important
to say, we recognize this
and this is what
we're doing about it.
Or what we even heard from
the feedback is, hey I get it.
If you can't do
everything because there's
just so much to do.
But at least can you tell
me that you're hearing it
and understand and explain
what is the other--
I see someone nodding.
You get it.
So we share this feedback
for the coming quarters
and then we say, OK, here
are potential projects,
but it's also a
filter in terms of who
are teams that we should be
partnering with to work out
these complex problems.
And that is what Prashanth
is going to talk about
in the engagement model.
PRASHANTH SANAGAVARAPU:
Thank You.
Engagements are
opportunities for your team
to work with other engineering
teams on a one on one basis
and focus on maximizing
the results of why
you are engaging with.
The idea here is to
generate automation,
or learning that could be
applied across the arc.
And we work with the
engineering teams
and we focus on maximizing
the results by following
our engagement model.
So if you are an SRE
engineering manager,
it's very important to
define who an SRE is,
and what his role
is or her role is.
And manage communications
and collaborations
across the team to build
that operational maturity.
But for that you have
to proactively define
all of that in your
engagement model.
You may ask why would we
need an engagement model.
When we did not have
an engagement model
we were still working with
teams and engaging with them.
However, the issue
there was we always
had misaligned priorities.
And we were in a situation
in one of our engagements
where whether focus
on capacity planning
or whether we want to
build on tooling app
that is like a blue-green
deployments on our Kubernetes
tooling that we provide
to our engineering teams.
So not just the
priority alignment.
But when we were dealing
with the culture change,
and there was an ops
team on we as an SRE team
we're working on the
engineering team,
they often looked at
us as ops engineers
who could do this one
off scripting for them.
But that's not what an SRE is.
We clearly defined that
in our engagement model
and put it in front of
our engineering teams.
And our model is based
off of shared goals.
If you read this
SRE workbook there's
a whole chapter on
how you should engage
with your engineering
teams, and I've
contributed the model
in detail on chapter 18.
But at a high level, it's
basis of shared goals.
As a team that is building
operational maturity
on other teams, my
goal is to build
something that can be
applied across the arc,
not just with them.
So we use our goals, and we
use engineering teams goals,
align them and call that
the scope of an engagement.
Once the shared goals
are set, the engineers
will sprint on the
milestones, and the managers
will keep the
communication and feedback
loop alive until the end
of the communication.
And we measure the impact by
performing operational maturity
assessments, appoint
them estimates
of operational maturity
before we begin the engagement
and after the
engagement is done.
And we derive the
metrics to compare
what the engagement results
are, and we publish them.
I'll walk you through
one of the examples.
As you've seen we
had this challenge
of having shared
views of reliability
across multiple teams.
So that we could capture
the user experience
and monitor our asset loss,
schedule a view of reliability
and Milestones 0.
We call it Milestone
0 because at the time
we did not really know what
the shared view of reliability
meant.
And how we would be build
that tooling that could
be applied across our arc.
So Milestone 0 is to
derive that requirements
and plan for the rollout.
This is a unique engagement
because what we did was
we approached our Google
TAM, and customer engineers
and put out our problems.
And they referred
to Google's SREs.
So we worked alongside
of Google SREs.
They were, like,
partners with our team.
They were participating
in regular check ins
to review what
SLOs really meant.
While we were working
with a frameworks team
that had multiple apps
built on that framework.
And built a tool that
could capture these SLOs
in a single pane of glass.
I'm not able to show the
exact framework SLOs here,
but this is our drone SLOs
built on the same tool.
But it's a place
where anyone can
see SLOs for all the
apps for that framework.
This is an example of how
you could involve Google SREs
alongside and get the benefit
of them to drive your goal.
Google SREs even did a workshop
for non-technical participants
in that engagement, and they
explained what SLOs really
meant, because it's really hard
to get SLOs right if you're
doing it for the first time.
And that was our first
time ever to have
standard SLOs rolled out.
Today we have this
tool, and we are
working on rolling that out.
So our engagements are not
just like tooling apps,
building operational maturity.
We also work, drive, special
events at the New York Times.
And Vinessa will talk about
one such special event.
VINESSA WAN: Thanks.
This is such an exciting time
to be at the New York Times.
Its events and
elections like this
that make me particularly proud
to be part of the organization.
And elections are
always special events.
But this year it's
been kind of different.
The political climate itself,
plus the attention to our site,
it's just been unprecedented.
And also since 2016 our digital
subscriptions have doubled.
We were expecting traffic for
a midterm like never before.
We formed a
cross-functional project,
and the mission was that
New York Times would remain
to be a key destination
for reliable, up to date,
election results.
It was a cross team effort.
And we wanted to ensure that
our news and interactive content
was stable, performant,
always up to date,
as our newsroom intends
to for our users.
And we also aimed
to minimize issues
in case they did come up.
And that we would also have a
minimum response and measures
in place to resolve
them quickly.
And I want you to remember,
this was our first ever event
like this on GCP.
Usually the scope for
elections typically
focuses on our interactive
and our publishing
content up through
what kind of call
the core stack of how it looks
to the end user on the site.
But, traditionally, we always
just take down the paywall.
Because it was just too
complex and just too costly
be able to do that for an event.
But now being able to
leverage GKE's auto
scaling and the
team's investment
in SRE as a discipline as
well as all the work they'd
done with test
automation, it let
them have better basics
in place with regards
to performance metrics.
Essentially, for the first time
our business and marketing team
was able to take advantage
of this surge in traffic
as a business opportunity.
We decided to leave
the paywall up
as a tactic to gain user
registrations on our site
so that later we could
reach out to those users
to see if they would be
interested in becoming
subscribers.
So this increased the scope.
And we were looking
at over 30 teams
that we needed to
assemble around readiness.
We were focused very much on
the technical readiness of it,
but it also did
involve coordination
with newsroom, marketing,
business, advertising.
So how did we
assemble this effort?
I remember being at Next
about a couple of years ago.
And there's a
really great talk--
I think GCP podcasts also
does an episode on it.
And it's Home Depot
with Google's SRE team,
and they're talking about the
preparation for Home Depot's
first Black Friday on GCP.
Both companies
partnered together.
They made an upfront
commitment to roll out
tooling and best practices.
And that Google would be in
the room with the Home Depot
all throughout Black Friday.
Home Depot's success
was Google's success.
Any failure on Home
Depot's site would also
be shared with Google.
It was a shared fate.
And so when I was asked
to be one of the project
managers, our project owner
being outside delivery
engineering, as well as a lot of
the other election leads on it,
we were wondering
how do we start?
What kind of work do we do?
And I immediately thought back
to that shared fate example.
We were able to partner with our
delivery engineering SRE team
to collaborate with them and
start mapping out the work
that we needed to get all these
teams ready for elections.
This work started
with doing a series
of architectural reviews.
We pooled representatives
from all these teams
in one big room, and they
went over their architecture
questions.
Like what fail-overs
did they have in place?
And our SRE team was able
to identify quick resiliency
wins that they could work on.
Prashanth mentioned a
lot of our challenges
with incident management because
teams were still reliant on us
a central system's
infrastructure team
to handle a lot of
their P1 incidents.
That just wouldn't
work during midterms.
Our team, as prep, had
started building up
training materials around
incident management
and what to do.
How people should actually
be managing an incident.
These are practices
actually inspired
by emergency response today.
And we train over 100 people
in the technology and newsroom
how to respond in case there
was a production incident, what
we also refer to as a P1.
And of course we partnered
with our Google TAMs.
They let us know on
day one of this project
that they would be
with us on site,
and we figured
out and documented
what are all the processes
that we needed to do,
and also what resources
would be available.
So if something happened,
they would be there for us.
The rapid duration
of the project,
we conducted stress test.
So increasing load
of the systems
to find out where the
vulnerabilities were.
Not only did this
help us technically,
but after each test we would
conduct the learning review
or blameless postmortem.
And we would do go
through the timeline
and then discuss,
where did we get lucky?
Where did things go right?
Where did things not go wrong?
And we didn't just talk about
it from a technical level.
This also helped
guide logistics.
Which teams had to sit
next to each other?
Because you can't put
30 teams in a war room.
But that also just gauged
what was the optimum way
that we needed to work and
communicate to make sure we
were successful on midterms.
So here is us during elections.
See if you can find-- can
anyone find Prashanth?
There he is.
Hi.
And he's there with
our Google rep,
and we're talking with
our interactive news team.
I could show more pictures, but
let's go through the results.
Now, I can't go through
particular details
with traffic and subscription.
But, yes, it was record
traffic for midterms.
You can see
particularly, one zoom
shot, is the
registration paywall.
You could before.
Can anyone guess the peak
when midterms happened?
About 40 times its traffic.
And then you could
even follow up
with a news bump in
the morning news cycle.
This allowed significant
registration growth.
And of course
incidents occurred.
We did have
production incidents,
but it was actually
really small.
And because we had put
all this preparation
into having responses in place
and fail-over plans in place.
We had very minimal user impact.
The resolution was
rapid and almost instant
in terms of the end
user experience.
So it's important to
celebrate events like this.
We talked about our mindset.
We talked about how
we work internally,
how we partner
engagement with teams.
But how do we
evangelize ourselves
across our organization?
I've worked on a lot of front
end teams and in advertising,
and it's kind of straightforward
to explain your success.
You could just point
to a front end feature.
You could point to
a revenue impact.
But our type of work,
it's hard to explain
to people in the business
that don't do what we do.
I often say we're kind
of like a stage crew.
You know, you don't realize our
success until things actually
break, and then it's-- yeah.
So we were also, though,
very inspired from feedback
that we got through
earlier feedback surveys.
And someone specifically
said, I do all this work
with your team.
And this has helped
me, but we don't really
get to talk about it this much.
We should share more
of these stories.
So inspired with that,
we decided to kick off
a project within our team.
We held New York Times first
ever internal tech conference.
Now, delivery
engineering internally
we abbreviate
ourselves to DV, and we
thought we'd do a fun little
word play on DevOps days,
so we did DV ops day.
Our CFP called out.
We want to know
what's working, what's
not working, even since
our cloud migrations in Q2?
And we wanted teams to
share their best practices
for operational support,
testing, tooling
and automation.
It was very important that we
reached out to the teams first.
Because, again, we want
to empower other teams.
We didn't want to
just be us talking.
And it wasn't.
We had 13 talks that included
presentation and demos
with topics like production
deployments with App Engine,
using HashiCorp Vault for
GCP service list solutions.
75% of these speakers
were outside of our team
and most of these speakers
were first time speakers
or it was a really long
time before they spoke.
We also had, in addition to
presentations and topics,
we had a workshop on how to
facilitate learning reviews.
And we also held
a panel comprised
of teams that went through
production readiness reviews
to talk about what
their experiences were
like in working with our team.
The majority of
volunteers that day
were also outside
our team, which
was also very impactful
to kind of just
get even anybody involved.
And it was a pretty snowy day.
We held the conference
on late January.
And if anyone's in from
New York you know it snows
and the commuting
is not that great.
But we actually had over
100 people sign up that day.
And that count doesn't
include all the people
who joined remotely.
One snippet from our panel.
This was from an audience
member who was specifically
talking about the panel
production readiness reviews.
How powerful it was.
And I think the other
takeaway from this
is that this person referred
to it of, wow your customers.
For us that was
already a big win.
So going forward
we're aiming to have
more of these events in tech.
If anything the feedback
was overwhelmingly,
we want more of these events.
We want to share more
of these stories.
I remember even
remembering Prashanth
and I on a elevator
ride down when
we were working on
this presentation,
there's a developer who ran
into us in the elevator.
He goes my goal next year is to
present at the next DV ops day.
So I'm going to hand
off to Prashanth
now, who's going to
talk more about how
we're looking forward.
PRASHANTH SANAGAVARAPU:
By no means
we have covered
all the challenges
that we have on the work that
we solved post migration.
Looking at 2019 and beyond, we--
sorry, it looks like--
There's a slide missing, but--
we're looking to build
operational maturity
on the teams.
Continue doing our engagement
with the teams to build tooling
and build stability
into our applications.
But the quick summary,
tools can reduce toil,
but SREs can impact by
partnering with teams
and building
operational maturity.
So, think about
engaging on teams
that are having specific
problems that could
be replicated elsewhere easily.
So you want to tackle those
through your engagements
and apply product
management mindset
to build that
operational majority,
because building operational
maturity is a culture change.
Treat your engineering
teams has your customers.
Ask feedback on a
regular cadence.
And source that back in as your
requirements for your tooling
or guidance.
And define an engagement
model that is goal oriented
and works for your team.
Because, as I mentioned,
engaging with your teams
is a key for your success.
Leverage your TAMs,
customer engineers.
They have insight
into what works
and what doesn't, because they
have more experience tapping
into the resources from Google.
And working with
Google SRE for us
has turned out into a
really great experience
because we were able
to get validation
from someone outside
of the company
to look at the tooling and the
SLOs that we were building.
And evangelize
your SRE practices
to stir up that culture change.
Last but not least,
celebrate your success.
We as a company are growing,
and my team is growing.
Please take a look
at our job site.
We're looking for
talented engineers.
I know I can see a lot here.
And check out our
blogs open.nytimes.com
where we talk about what we do.
[MUSIC PLAYING]